once uh again
and let's do it
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to your favorite podcast
[Music]
[Applause]
if it's your first time
thanks for being here if you be if
you're here all the time welcome back to
ripping with Griffin the comedy
non-comedy podcast today Wednesday on
Netflix book club
um Antonio Banderas
with the Zorro controversy
um what else
um it's a couple other things but
anyways everybody welcome back
[Music]
ripping with Griffin yeah baby like I
say welcome back to riffing with Griffin
go to Eric griffin.com thanks for being
here I appreciate when you subscribe
share and all that stuff hit the
notifications hit the like button as
soon as you get on I appreciate that I'm
on Twitch Eric Griffin gave me it's a
way to support and follow me you could
be a subscriber on Twitch which is great
you could be a subscriber on the member
on YouTube
um if you want to support and you like
the show uh patreon you know I always
say I'm gonna do something on patreon
and I just I never can get it together
because I'm shooting I'm traveling I
gotta figure this out everybody else
does it right I gotta figure it out too
a lot of different ways to support me so
I appreciate that uh once again welcome
back
and like I say if this is your first
time hearing you think this is a comedy
podcast uh you know what I'm leaning
into who I am if you want to seem uh a
comedy podcast portion or me comedy
podcast person go check me out on the
golden hour golden hour with Brendan
Schaub Chris D'Elia pretty funny on
there even Jen to Jen with Matthew
Espinosa that's another great podcast I
do uh check me out there we're trying to
build that one up but this one is a
hodgepodge of a lot of different things
I talk sports politics uh I do movie
reviews book reviews I give advice
sometimes it's fun sometimes it's funny
sometimes it's silly but it's
authentically who I am that's what this
podcast is so if you're looking for some
silly funny stuff go someplace else uh
or stick around because you might see
that too but this is like you know
riffing with Griffin and sometimes I'm
uh introspective and very serious and
other times I'm like you know silly as
can be but anyways it is who it is good
morning everybody and welcome to the
podcast so here we are um what's going
on um oh before I even get started with
that uh this week y'all this week I will
be in Chicago
Chicago
I'm coming your way to Zanies
maybe Chicago downtown December 1st
through the 3rd
come on check me out last month of
2022-21 or what is it is it 22 whatever
it is
[Music]
Chicago see you
all right yeah I had to do my little uh
commercial so come check me out there's
any Chicago hey that music was loud huh
well whatever it is what it is so
um what else is going on so yeah I just
I just got back from Dallas shout out to
everybody in Dallas that was great shows
at uh the Improv in Addison so that was
good one night I did I did had this one
situation one night like this guy was
sitting like close to the front row and
he was like making he was talking he
kept yelling out it looked like he was
like drunk or high
or even like mentally disabled you know
what I'm saying like I I don't know
which one it was it was that kind of
outburst where I was like what is this
guy okay and that's always tough too if
somebody I don't know if like I've had
this happen before where somebody in the
crowd is like legit mentally disabled
you know some kind of thing and they
just brought them the family brought him
to the show and he's you know he's kind
of acting out it's like you know
whatever and then you don't know how to
respond you know what I mean sometimes
you want to be like yo shut up you know
you want to be you know but then it's
kind of like you find that out and
you're like oh but at the same time I'm
also like yo why is it why'd you bring
this dude to the show this is this ain't
the time for that you know what I mean
like people sometimes put you in an
uncomfortable situation because they
being selfish you know it's like
bringing kids to a to a play or
something and they're running around and
you're like yo this is some adult stuff
I'm trying to enjoy and I'm not nothing
against your kid but this ain't the time
or place same kind of thing but anyways
the dudes three times I I didn't say
anything
you know and you can see the people
around him just being like what are you
doing especially when you like working
on you're doing material I'm doing jokes
man I'm doing material that I have
planned out and then like in the middle
of it somebody wants to yell out like
that you know anyways
at a certain point I was like yo man you
need to shut up I told I've ignored you
three times anyways but after that the
show I gotta say the show was a little
weird it was intense
then later the next day I get a message
on Instagram from somebody and this
person's all like hey man
how do you say they were like you went
up you you went you you went too hard on
that guy and you know some of us in the
back we didn't know what was going on so
then it just you know it made us
uncomfortable and it was like weird okay
you know
and then it's weird because I'll get a
message from someone else who will be
like oh my God thank you for shutting
down that guy he was disturbing the show
I bring this up to say you can't please
everybody and and that's the difficult
part about a stand-up comedy environment
I mean to think about a stand-up comedy
environment is that all these people are
in this room who don't know each other
and have different
backgrounds different social economic
you know backgrounds different
upbringings different religious
political all kinds of different things
and they're in this room and everybody
thinks they know how stuff is supposed
to go or how you're supposed to act
it was weird I don't know I'm not it
wasn't weird it was like it's just
reminded me of that that fact man it
just reminded me of that I was like man
this this can go any which way so weird
uh anyways welcome to the uh you know to
the chat also this is once again this is
live I'm doing this live I see you in
the chat
um
and um
you know thanks you know I'm looking at
you guys is here too so thanks for being
here with that so all right so let's get
into some of the things I wanted to talk
about today so one of the things was
like there's a big thing right now push
for like uh sobriety you know there's a
lot of like sober things going on you
know and if people had the sober October
and or no drink November or whatever
they have this like that I mean I'm just
telling my own personal journey is I
don't I've never I've never been drunk
in my life I don't I don't drink alcohol
I I I could I could tell you the handful
of times I've had alcohol in my life
I had half a beer in high school because
everybody else was drinking and I was
like okay I guess this is what you're
supposed to do it was nasty as hell I
was like no thank you
um I went on vacation with a buddy of
mine uh I you know Workaholics was going
well and I was like I've never gone on a
vacation so I went with my buddy who and
he was like I he was like okay you got a
drink though you got to have you got to
test it out so like I remember I had
champagne on the flight over champagne
is like Ugh whatever I don't like wine
I don't like the taste so she it was
like whatever okay uh
uh we get there it's we're on this beach
you know and I um I ordered from the bar
a banana colada okay and I'm tasting it
and my first thought was
man they they don't ruin this great
shake with this nasty bitter thing so I
didn't like that
and then
the next day at the hotel bar
they have like drink of the day they had
this like specialty drink of the day I
don't know what was in it but I was like
I'll try that man I had like maybe this
month like an inch of that and I was
done I was like Ugh my head was hurting
I was like I'm done with this I'm never
doing this again
so I just I never that's my journey and
then I have someone very close to me in
my life who you know is an alcoholic you
know what I mean
and it's in recovery so I have my own
you know experience with them my own
PTSD with you know people because when
you're close to someone and they are
just destroying themselves with drugs
and alcohol it is a really tough thing
to deal with you blame yourself for not
doing enough then you know then you got
people telling you that let them hit
rock bottom and you're just like
whatever so there's like a movement
right now I think that you you hear a
lot about like you know uh people being
sober there's a lot of studies about it
you know and I think that
um as time goes on and science is
getting more advanced you know you hear
about studies from like you know 10 20
years ago so now you're starting to see
some of the results and some of the
things that they're saying so like one
of the articles I looked up
um for this topic was where's my here it
is let me see if this is going to work
stream capture yeah there you go alcohol
and your health is none better than a
little so that's the thing too because
you know you hear people say like well
you should like the doctor says you
should have a glass of wine a night and
all this kind of stuff and there's
actually now now studies saying that
that's that's not true that the
qualities that that whatever that is in
wine that is good for you for for you to
really receive those benefits you would
have to drink so much wine and then
you're talking about how does alcohol
affect your brain and then it's a whole
other subject so I don't know so
like I was reading this and they're
talking about wait let me see if I can
zoom in on this a little bit there we go
all right so in June so then you you see
they got these studies like look at this
one in 2018 a study published in a
journal
p-o-p-l-o-s medicine found that among
older adults light drinking in the range
of one to four drinks per week was
associated with a slightly lower risk of
death compared to zero consumption so
that was like a study that was done in
2018 that is saying like hey you know
people that don't drink you're gonna die
die more than people that do drink so
it's like that gives me some thoughts
like that affects me my mind I mean so
many people I know right now in my age
range
um a handful I should say have died
recently you know and it's starting you
know you start thinking about your own
mortality and it's like he's gonna go oh
[__] this is something else
okay so then they go in August in 2018
two larger studies examined the impact
of alcohol the first one published in
the landsat included only people who
drank at least some alcohol it concluded
that the common recommendations
regarding moderate drinking is one drink
a day or less for women and two drinks
per day or less for men might be too
much okay wow the second study was even
bigger it examined data from hundreds of
studies and sources including sales of
alcohol home brewed alcoholic beverage
consumption and even estimates of
tourist consumption in the 195 locations
and it analyzed the overall health
impact related to alcohol consumption
including death and disability due to
autumn automobile accidents infectious
diseases cancer and cardiovascular
disease it concluded that the best
option for overall health was no
drinking at all I repeat it concluded
that the best option for overall health
was no drinking at all of note the
definition of drink in the study was 10
grams of alcohol that's 30 percent less
than the standard drink in the U.S but
25 more than the standard drink in the
UK
so you know
I mean anything that like kills brain
cells and you know
I mean I I just don't know you know what
I mean
I don't know how I feel about it man I
don't want to sound like a party poop or
anything like that like I made my choice
for my own personal I just didn't like
the taste there's two reasons why I
don't drink
I don't like the taste and two I don't
like not being in control of myself
I don't like the idea that like I am not
myself and so therefore I can't drive or
I can't be trusted to think properly I
just don't like feeling that feeling
there's nothing about it that appeals to
me like I like when people get black out
drunk and the next day you're like Yo
dude you they don't remember anything if
you don't remember it what was the point
of doing it
I just I don't understand that so like
if you had the choice if it was a would
you rather okay
would you rather
not drink any alcohol
let me see what let me think of the let
me say this in the best way because
here's here's because here's really what
it is would you rather have a boring
night that you remember
or have
uh the best night of your life that you
don't remember the next day at all which
one is it oh I should do a poll huh
and if you want to if you want to say
something in the uh in the um comments
because you're listening later I would
love to hear what you say
um
you know so let me write it okay would
you rather
have a boring night
have a boring night you remember
everything
or okay night of your life but you
don't remember
okay which one would you uh
you know what I mean what do you guys
think
okay how come you can't
I don't understand
the pl it doesn't work
oh because I have too much
um
oh yes two there you go there you go
there you go wait and this one's too
long oh wow Jesus
uh not of your life
[Laughter]
uh okay yeah there's two you can only
put so many words there you go there you
go there you go I don't know if it's
that's just abbreviated version
you know baby version
um
yeah so that's just that's really the
question you have to ask yourself
because I just don't understand it and I
know I guess like the the the middle
ground of that is like oh you have a few
drinks and you have a I hear I hear
people that drink always say to me like
well I love that buzz there's like a
there's like a level of drinking where
they're like oh I'm there in the in this
sort of like buzz zone of fun but I mean
it seems to me that you know a lot of
people they they can't stay in that zone
they keep drinking and then now what I
mean look at all back uh oh obj uh uh
you know he he just was you know Odell
Beckham Jr was drunk on a plane and they
kicked him off it's like so whatever
night he had before
it affected his you know it could be
detrimental to his life
financially I mean you know what I mean
like people might be like hey I don't
want this guy
oh sorry to hear that Nathan everybody
in the chat everybody listening our boy
Nathan here he got dumped and he says
tell me everything's gonna be okay
everything is gonna be okay dude but
just because you it's okay to feel what
you're feeling right now like feel what
you're feeling take it all in eat some
ice cream watch a movie that makes you
cry listen to a song that makes you
emotional and then start hanging out
with your friends start working out
start doing Hobbies start doing things
is going to make you forget just improve
yourself right now you're hurting so
deal with the pain it's totally okay
that's normal all right
um well it looks like people are saying
most of you guys are saying night of
your life and don't remember that's
interesting
so anyway to get back to it and thanks
for the super chat too Nathan
um you got some two dollar therapy right
there so
um
you know oh I gotta you know
speaking of would you rather
I was doing Jen to gen with Matthew and
oh no no that wasn't no it was on uh it
was on um it wasn't on gender gen but we
do would you rathers on there all the
time but it was actually on Golden hour
so we're doing golden hour and this guy
gave us the most mind-blowing would you
rather and I'm still thinking about it
so it was like you have your wife or
girlfriend and it's about your like so
if your mom and your girlfriend Freaky
Friday okay so your mom's brain your
mom's personality and brain her
Consciousness is inside your wife
girlfriend's body and vice versa and the
only way
the only way to flip it back is you have
to have sex with one of them
[Laughter]
which one would it be oh man
that's a let that let that go in your
brain man
[Laughter]
so anyways
all right um what else is going on so oh
I want to talk about so anyways back to
you know
I don't know so if you're out there and
you make it just make good choices man
you know like I always say if you're a
young person especially a young woman
you know if you know you're gonna drink
you're gonna take drugs you're gonna
just go out you're gonna party you're
gonna live your best life make sure you
have somebody with you that you trust
you know that's all I'm saying I'm not
telling you not to drink but I'm telling
you to be safe and to look out for
yourself if there's any younger girls
watching this and I doubt that there is
but if you are if you're a dad or a mom
with somebody young you know you know
you're gonna tell them don't drink don't
drink they're still gonna do it you know
what you want to do is you want to make
sure in my opinion that they understand
uh how like how to do it like you know
hey have a partner don't just trust
don't just be drinking with people you
don't know you know what I mean use your
instincts use your gut you know don't
just be Reckless because that's how
things happen you know that's how things
happen bad things happen to good people
in those situations
okay so you know what I haven't done
this in a while and it's just gonna be
quick but uh you know you guys know I I
read a lot of audiobooks uh I'm a big
audiobook guy
and I um
I one of the books
this new author I've been listening to
because I have Audible and I think
audible's great by the way if you listen
to audiobooks his name is Pedro irvey
urvi I don't even know if that's how you
spell his name but his name's Pedro Irby
and I'm I'm reading this a series of his
he's got a bunch of series and I'm gonna
I'm gonna check out some of these other
series but if you're if you need a
record if you like I love fantasy I love
fantasy books I love dragons and uh old
world nights and or nights at around
table and magic and those are my
favorite type of uh fantasy books and so
right now I'm reading this series called
the path of the Ranger and there's I
didn't look at there's 16 books and oh
I'm catching up because that one isn't
going to come out until 2023 but I'm
like on book
uh seven the King of the West so I've
I've listened to all six books up to
that point and I gotta say like the
overall I really love this series but
you really are following this character
through some stuff and some of it's kind
of you might think it's boring you know
like I would say that path of the
specialist was a book where I was like
wow you're really getting into detail
about like this guy's training you know
so it's a you know it's uh but it you
know it's in this medieval sort of
universe and
um the the hero is big is the hero's
mother and father
you know the the father
the father is thought of as a traitor
because of a choice that he made and and
the mother supposedly died and you find
out some things about this and his life
and you know he becomes a reigner and a
ranger is like this skilled Archer like
Assassin type person so he goes to
because his father was that so he goes
to to this you know Ranger school to
like learn how to shoot the bow and
arrow and he meets a bunch of people he
becomes friends with people and you just
kind of and he's there's magic involved
and you just kind of go on this journey
with him and the way the author writes
it it's super detailed account of almost
like a diary of this person's everyday
life and then you and the person that's
doing the reading the reader is really
great and you start to like really get
into this story and you really kind of
want to know what's going on and you're
like following along you kind of get
used to the style and I think the author
is like really good I think he's a
really good author like how he you know
like I said the detail that he gives and
like really explaining like what it
means to be a ranger what it means to uh
you know what it means
to his friendships and all this stuff
and
having honor and uh putting you in like
sort of dilemmas like having to choose
between country and friend and Foe and
enemy it's really good you know so shout
out to him and I just wanted to give you
a quick recommendation
about
you know what I mean about uh you know
if you're into like reading fantasy
books but this is probably it's a great
read too if you want to like go buy a
book but this guy's got a great
great uh flow so anyways that's my
recommendation for Pedro Irving good
dude it's a good book so now let's get
into something else here
that I wanted to talk about is
so apparently Antonio Banderas
and this I Antonio Banderas apparently
named he he was saying he thinks that
Tom Holland should be the next Zorro and
of course
this is going into a bunch of like you
know
a bunch of stuff about
race gender and who should be what and
you know how ya we whitewash things or
you know and even Antonio Banderas
himself like I don't know if he even
considers himself Latino who even knows
I think he's actually from Spain I don't
think he's from like but who I don't
even know the origins of Zorro
I guess we can look up Zorro but of
course this is like
one of these things that's going to come
up and people are gonna there's two
sides of the coin one person's gonna be
like hey it shouldn't matter it's all
about their performance and then someone
else is going to be like yo this is a
Latin hero shouldn't this person be
Latin so you kind of got to figure out
you know how you're gonna do that and
you know the thing is is like
um
we can't just go off the history of
Hollywood you know things are different
now like how are we gonna handle things
now you know I mean Hollywood for so
long you know John Wayne was playing
a Asian guy he was being he was Genghis
Khan you know what I mean like
you know like that's just what they did
in Hollywood man and so things were like
that for so long that we kind of just go
yeah whatever about it but it's now
becoming a thing where this is important
to people
um and I'm kind of 50 50 on it I would
say I just wanted to make sense that's
my thing it should make sense that's all
like let's not get into uh you know oh
the best person for the job like who
cares about that that's not the first
thing to me it's like it should make
sense also within this universe that
you're creating
if Zorro is
not Latino
explain it in the story you know like is
he Tarzan all of a sudden like a you
know a white family law the parents died
or the parents live in Latin America and
they raised their son to be like these
people need a hero and you're that hero
then freaking you know explain that in
the story and then we might be on board
we'll be like oh okay so zoro's a white
guy white he lives in this place in his
family you know but if not then it
should make sense that's all and it
makes sense that Zorro would be freaking
Latino it just makes sense because he's
from this region he's the hero of the
region he probably grew up in the region
and he's there so it would make sense
then hire someone who looks like that
okay now here's where it gets tricky
it could be a white guy
who looks Latino or with the right
makeup
is Latino or I like
it just needs to make sense you know
when we look at whatever we're looking
at we want that to represent properly
now when it comes to like now we're
getting into politics of like what
people think things should be
I'm not a believer that like if the
characters Mexican in the movie that the
person should be Mexican
because could they be a Guatemalan actor
a Colombian actor a Honduran actor uh or
you know and and they're just playing
this is that okay
uh what about
you know you know what I'm saying like
is so like Selena you know like was
Jennifer is Jennifer Lopez from the same
place as Selena is she just was she the
same kind of Latina as I don't even know
what I'm saying is there are differences
but it's like do you want to get it down
to that where it's like only the people
from the place can play the person like
I don't want to get into that you know
uh so I don't know where you stand on
that and it looks like
the Palm ending the poll but you know
it's just it's it's it's it's a really
touchy
it's a really touchy subject
that people are making a huge deal about
right now and I I'm kind of like it's to
me it's very nuanced
you know I love that word it's a nuanced
subject that I just don't
I I actually I actually understand both
sides and I lean towards the side of I
lean towards the side of generally let's
have this person be
you know look the part and then why not
hire an actor
in the general realm of that so if it is
a Latino part yeah let's get a Latino
person there's plenty of Latino Charming
fun Latino actors that can play Zorro
you don't need to give it to a white guy
uh you know
there's there's that part of it and I
understand that being a person of color
myself where like you know I go out for
things and it's like I'm not even going
out for
uh what they originally wrote the part
for that I'm just kind of like
convincing them that I can do it you
know
so it's like it's not necessarily about
being woke it's not some wokeness so
much as it's about like yeah there are
not a lot of opportunities and so you
know let's give people the opportunities
or let them at least give them the
opportunity to fight for it right
I mean I'm so multi-ethnic that it's
like people don't even know what I am so
it's like there's no there's no thing
for that you know
it's like even for me I've been on like
some I've been on black shows at doing
comedy I've been on Latino shows doing
comedy I've been on like mainstream
shows you know it's like who who are who
am I what do I play where do I fit in
you know so it just it's it's one of
those it's one of those like sort of
like dilemmas that Hollywood is in right
now based off how people are talking
about it so we just have to decide but
in this particular instance it's like
you know
we can't ignore the history of Hollywood
sort of like ignoring race and it just
being like everything will just have
somebody white do it because they didn't
think anybody else could do it or
something like look I'm not a person
that like I I think we should move on
from things but we can't forget our
racist past we can't we can't forget it
and how it affects us now you know I
mean it's like I I here's a good analogy
for you in my opinion it's like a pool
you know so we have this pool of water
that's now dirty we have this dirty pool
in our backyard and there was there was
a lot of things that happened people
drowned in this pool or there was
accidents around this pool and now we
have to clean the pool out so we got to
take out all the dirty water we have to
clean the pool we have to put new water
in it but it's hard to look at this pool
and not remember the things that have
happened that's what we're trying to do
right now we're trying to live our lives
right now well we can go back and swim
and not remember that someone died here
or not or you know what I mean the PTSD
of like the past of the United States we
have to sort of get past it but we can't
forget it so it's it's like a catch-22
man so this [__] is very nuanced so
I totally understand especially and who
and we can't speak for Latinos like if
Latino people are like yo what will you
taken look taking Zorro like can we can
we have Zorro please that's people's
right to feel how they want to feel and
it's not our right to like
to Discount people's feelings you know
so
anyways it is what it is
I you know however you feel about it if
you want to have a discussion about it
in the uh
um
comments I love that kind of stuff but
you know like I always say
you know can you just comment
without it being like rude and
disrespectful I mean there is something
about people these keyboard Warriors
that are out there that think like
how I'm gonna start is you're an idiot
blah blah blah you know it's like yo
let's have a discussion hey I
respectfully disagree or I think this I
mean and I know and I also know that
there's white people listening with a
majority of podcast listeners to me are
probably white anyway uh you know y'all
are all you know y'all are feeling the
way you're feeling too like hey I didn't
do anything it wasn't me you know it's
like you have some feelings about it too
so it's like it's okay to have whatever
your perspective is and you know I'm all
about a good
a good healthy discourse so
talk about that you know what I mean
you know what I mean yeah you know what
I mean
okay so let us go into
[Music]
this not gonna be a long episode but let
us go into
um my review you know I don't know if
there's gonna be I don't I don't think
there'll be any spoilers spoiler alert
should we have a spoiler alert
um I want to talk about Wednesday on
Netflix and you know here's the thing
too man
like this show is actually
The Adams Family is actually a great
you know a thing about this because
um
it's like we're The Adams Family why
you know were they were they were they
supposed to be white I don't know uh you
know the guy's name was Gomez you know
go and uh Morticia was white so they're
probably mixed it's probably a mixed
family
you know but I don't know but
um I do want to talk about this
particular show
it's a Tim Burton joint you know I think
he's the executive producer of the show
um created by Alfred
go go or I don't know go
reminds me my stepfather's last name
Crow
and Miles Miller I think uh like I said
I think Tim Burton is like Yeah Tim
Burton is one of the directors executive
producer of the show
it Stars this girl that you see right
here Jenny Ortega
um
guys I'm telling you right now this show
is fabulous like I have never loved a
show this much in
um for so many reasons in a long time
this is like so the show is about like
if you know the Adams Family you know
the Adam family
I used to love The Adams Family when I
was a kid it was like I would watch the
monsters and Adams Family and The Adams
Family is this sort of like
it's sort of like it's really tricky to
play this right because
they were this sort of family that they
found a way to like comically
comically
talk about like how morbid and like not
evil they were but like how in a funny
way how they were into like murder in
like the occult demonic stuff and like
you know they just found this fun
comedic way to express that that they
were people that you know that liked
that this sort of like morbid side of
life you know it was it it's uh it's a
it's a really uh weird thing that of how
they they play it and so sometimes it's
played Super corny and there's been many
movies that have come out and TV shows
and cartoons to try to express it uh you
know Christina Ricci she became really
famous from playing Wednesday she did a
really great job and Wednesday is this
sort of like really like cold that look
on this girl's face right here is that's
Wednesday you know what I mean she never
smiles she doesn't hug you know she's
she likes to torture her her little
brother you know they're into torture in
Mayhem and you know what I mean it's
like
so there's a lot of like
you know that in it so you cut to now
this is like a new iteration of the show
where they're just sort of following
Wednesday who they have to send off to
boarding school at this sort of like
Harry potter-ish type School anytime
there's like magic werewolves Vamp
anything like that and there's a school
it's it always reminds me of Harry
Potter you know what I mean like the
most famous Magic School of all time so
Wednesday's going off to this uh you
know this school this sort of boarding
school that her parents went to and it's
like a lot of Teen Angst and this girl
is playing it like this is a role of a
lifetime for somebody in my opinion like
she's doing such a great job she is a
phenomenal actress and I can't give her
enough Kudos this young girl Jenny
Ortega I'm not sure even how old she is
I think she might be like 17 or
something like that or she might be
playing it I don't know
um okay so she was born in 2002 so yeah
she's like 19. so she's playing that
he's playing a young she's playing young
you know uh but like
she is so believable
so believable
the nuances of her performance
like
you you believe her you believe what's
happening uh and her feelings and and
I'm totally on board the moment you
follow her and you're just like seeing
how she reacts to things it's great and
the it's such a well told story arc from
episode one to episode eight you know
there's things that happen you know that
they build up towards for her personally
as a as a character like to watch this
sort of dark morbid character who had so
much personality and Charisma from
episode one to see her evolve and change
because of the environment and things
that are happening to her to see like
her relationship with her mom her
relationship with herself her
relationship with like trying to like
make friends and and like who but she's
anti-friend and she's a loner and and
then the special effects of like thing
which is just a hand and you you know
you had Uncle Fester show up and Lurch
is there and you know Morticia and Gomez
and then you know they had this like you
know the most romantic romance on
television history besides Montez and
Colleen if I will say so myself
you know just you know it's just you
still had all that and then she carries
it I hope they make a second season and
I'm a super fan of this chick now Jenny
Ortega I can't wait to see her do other
things because she is such a giving
actress
you know what I mean and uh you know
this is just one of those really
fantastic
uh new shows you know what I mean so
it's like I don't know if you guys
have seen it I mean has anybody seen it
who's seen it if you've seen it and what
do you think of it I I just think it's
really good yeah Catherine Zeta Jones is
in it you know she does a great job as
Morticia and then uh what's the guy's
name that's wait let me get the cast
where's the cast cast
I'm still on her [__] let me go off oh
here we go
so it's
um
yeah you got Jenny Ortega and Gwendolyn
Christie that really tall actress who's
in who was in uh um Game of Thrones you
know like she played she does a great
job like literally everybody in this
movie does a really great job you know
so it's like you know you got the high
school angst you know what I mean and
it's like I like how it's done where
there's not like this is the villain
this is the hero you know
I will say this though I did guess who
the villain was episode five or six
so so something happens where they say
they describe a character they describe
something that happens to a character
and I've watched enough shows and movies
and stuff to know I was like oh that's
the I knew who the villain was but it
still didn't stop me from enjoying the
show you know what I mean it didn't stop
me from enjoying the show and she's like
Wednesday she's like a like a really
analytical uh she's she's being a
detective and she and then I gotta say I
can't sing enough Praises for Jenny
Ortega so
um like great job I highly recommend
this show one like one thousand percent
recommend this show and this show gets
10 woo-woos you know this is a 10
woo-woo show for the first time
so 10 woo-woos for um
excuse me
10 wubus from Wednesday on Netflix and
so if you have seen the show the you
know let me know let me know what you
think of the show you know if you don't
like it I totally get it you don't
always have to take my recommendations
if you don't like my recommendations I
totally understand you know what I mean
I'm just giving you my thoughts you
watch the show because it's my thoughts
um and if you have some other shows you
that you want me to watch oh yeah Luis
Gomez you lose Guzman I'm sorry Lewis
Guzman is playing Gomez and he's doing a
great job too you know what I mean
um yes the loving
you know Gomez Adams so Adam's Family
pretty pretty dope
make sure you guys check that out all
right guys you know
I didn't even have any ads today so this
is just gonna be like one of those
episodes where you know we move on from
I just gotta find
I gotta you know my I still have this
thing with my phone where I lost all my
folders so annoying man so annoying you
know I put a a a what did I put it like
a what is it not a meme but I put like a
a thing on a on the um
on the front page you know what I mean
what's it called what are those things
called
um a widget right I put a widget and
then all of the apps flew out of all the
folders because I put this widget on the
thing
it's just like man I'm so mad about that
dude and so now I now it's like hard to
find things and it's like you know you
have these flat so many great folders
for all the different apps and I knew
where to find them so now I'm just all
messed up you know what I mean just
really annoying so but anyways I want to
thank you all for watching and listening
to riffin with Griffin once again and
check me out in Chicago all you uh
Chicago people I'm gonna be at Zanies in
in downtown Chicago
um December 1st through the 3rd that's
this weekend Thursday Friday Saturday so
come check me out there
foreign
and now as we do every week it's time
with one of these fishy Beats
for the rap recap
I don't drink
cause I don't want to get clapped
wanna keep my senses
not trying to get slapped
that's how we do it
oh Griffin
this is Eric Griffin
you know I'm ripping
book club
person to the book in a tub
E
when it stay on Netflix that show suit
for the [__]
Jenny Ortega
nothing rhymes with Ortega
that show was pretty good and another
one of the
another rap recap
so make sure you check it out
Step Up
thank you
give me some death
thanks for watching y'all
and I will see you next week